so today we're going to talk about
vitamin b9 there's a couple different
versions one is folic acid one is folate
folic acid is the synthetic version
which I recommend you avoid and then you
have full egg which is the natural
version and the reason I want to bring
this up is that vitamin b9 is very very
important in many chemical reactions in
the body and especially in turning genes
on and turning them off and DNA repair
so if you're deficient and b9 you can
have a lot of body issues in vitamin b9
is a very common deficiency simply
because the enzyme that helps you
convert folate or folic acid to the
active form of b9 which is methylfolate
uses this enzyme which is commonly
mutated so there are different types of
mutations or alterations in different
groups of people and some mutations
create no problem at all
others create huge problems with the
absorption of folate in fact 30 to 50
percent of the population has some form
of mutation in this gene and out of this
population you have various degrees of
absorption some people can absorb more
than others but the point is that a lot
of people are deficient in this active
form of b9 not having this vitamin work
in the body can lead to a lot of issues
one would be high homocysteine which can
create risk of getting a stroke heart
attack hearing loss many other symptoms
another deficiency symptom would be
increasing risk of cancer a heart
disease in fertility migraine headaches
depression and other problems with your
neurotransmitters and inability to
detoxify so you have one problem of not
getting enough of that nutrient but the
other problem is getting too much of the
synthetic version if you have a problem
with this gene and you're taking or
being exposed to this synthetic form of
b9 you're going to have a lot of
additional
problems so then the question is how
might you beginning folic acid well one
is they fortify a lot of the grains with
folic acid another common exposure would
be the vitamins that you're taking if
you're buying your vitamins from the
drugstore or even a helpful store in
their synthetic make sure it does not
have this version right here we get our
natural folate from dark leafy green
vegetables you can get them from organ
meats but very few people consume like
beef liver let alone consume enough
vegetables so just from a diet
standpoint a lot of people are deficient
in this nutrient right here one test
that you can do to determine if you have
a problem with this is it's called
23andme it's an online site and you can
order the test and find out if you have
a problem with this if you do then this
is the the version of b9 that you want
to take it's called methyl full-length
it's easy to find you can go to the
health store or order online but I would
also recommend taking at the same time a
high quality vitamin b12 you want to get
the methyl version of b12 as well it's
called methylcobalamin and not the
synthetic version which is the cyano
Cibola main you want to get the methyl
version alright guys thanks for watching
and I will talk to you soon hey if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos